taking it to the streets
unionists indigenous and pro-government
movements marched to the presidential
Palace hitting the call of Colombia's
president to defend this controversial
social reforms it is Gustavo Petro's
preferred strategy in times of Crisis
crayon
thought a cornered petrol would abandon
the idea of a great transformation but
this is not our destiny that's not why
we are here our function in the history
of Colombia is to make the reforms
succeed
comes just days after Petro dismissed
seven cabinet ministers mostly members
of the country's political establishment
replacing them with close allies
heart of the crisis is Petrus
controversial Healthcare reform plan
which would reduce the involvement of
private entities and give the state more
control over funds but his plan has been
lagging in Congress
green party Senator Ariel Avila says the
cabinet breakup signals the end of
Petro's broad governing Coalition but
his reformist agenda could be difficult
to realize with a weakened face in
Congress
the government presented 35 reforms of
this four the so-called social reforms
are the most controversial and have led
to the breakdown of the Coalition the
government now will try to negotiate
votes with each Congressman then when it
sees that many of his reforms will fail
Petra will try with the street democracy
he will try to promote a referendum to
approve the reform critics consider the
abrupt Shake upcoming just nine months
into Petros Administration as a possible
radicalization on part of a president
that has shown little patience for
descent and the move has also sent shock
waves to the currency and bond markets
the most worrying loss for the markets
was the sacking of Finance Minister Jose
Antonio Campo an internationally admired
Economist who many observers saw as a
wall of protection against radical moves
better replaced them with Ricardo
Bonilla another seasoned Economist but
one who observers fear will simply do as
is told the president may be Keen to
make some decisions about cost controls
price increases for for fuel
additional subsidies or even an
extraordinary increase in the minimum
wage so each of those lines in the sand
represent opportunities for Bonita to
say stop no and show if he will rise to
the occasion and fill the big shoes that
Ocampo left behind
Peter will be hoping to push labor
pension and health reform to Congress in
the next couple of weeks but it will
have to do it with declining support in
the polls and Shake Economic Times ahead
showing just how difficult it will be to
fulfill his promise of change Alessandro
Al Jazeera Bogota